y nuevamente hablamos de la economía del
mundo en directo' américa con daniela
blandón danny vamos a comenzar en
américa latina porque ya se toman
medidas por esta guerra que está pasando
en ucrania claro que si raúl e iniciamos
en perú en donde rige desde hoy un toque
de queda en lima y callao por las
protestas de transportadores que
iniciaron hace una semana y que ya se
tornaron violentas la razón es que la
guerra ha traído una alza dramática en
los precios del petróleo y esto como
consecuencia trae que también suben los
precios de la gasolina también han
provocado escasez de los fertilizantes
que vienen de rusia y de los que este
país perú depende en gran parte el
gobierno respondió exonerando el fin de
semana hasta junio próximo el impuesto
al consumo de gasolina y de diesel y
aumentando el salario mínimo en un 10% a
1.205 soles por mes lo que al día de hoy
equivale a unos 332 dólares sin que esto
apaciguar a los ánimos y es que dani
también está guerra en vez de impactar
seriamente la economía de nuestra región
clara porque además de las clases de los
fertilizantes que usualmente bien en
américa latina' a precios bastante desde
rusia también está el aumento de los
precios del petróleo que a su vez eleva
el costo de los combustibles y también
el transporte de alimentos entre otros
te tengo otro ejemplo el gobierno de
uruguay radicó un proyecto de ley que
permite eliminar por un mes el iva al
pan blanco y a las pastas que han subido
de precio
estrepitosamente y es que rusia y
ucrania pues proveen una tercera parte
del trigo mundial y los ministros de
economía y finanzas europeas se reúnen
en luxemburgo claro pues llegaron por
ahora a la conclusión de que las
sanciones de la unión europea sobre el
petróleo y el carbón rusos son
definitivamente una opción pero
solamente si los estados miembros pueden
llegar a un consenso y eso es lo que
todavía no ha ocurrido otro tema de
fondo de la reunión fue el impuesto
mínimo en las sociedades que se ha
venido discutiendo durante los últimos
años los ministros económicos del bloque
europeo estaban intentando por segunda
vez en menos de un mes alcanzar un
acuerdo unánime para establecer este
gravamen pero este martes polonia
bloqueó la propuesta de francia sobre
cómo
y con un solo con su solo voto pues esta
discusión ya queda para el próximo mes y
le explico rápidamente raúl lo que
significa casi 140 países llegaron a un
acuerdo en octubre sobre una tasa
impositiva mínima del 15 por ciento para
las multinacionales en ese sentido
acordaron dificultar las cosas para que
empresas como google amazon o facebook
llevan impuestos por la vida de poner
sus ganancias en jurisdicciones de
impuestos bajos pero faltan los últimos
detalles sobre la implementación y el
suelo difícil de conseguir vamos a ver
entonces qué va a pasar con esta
dificultad que tienen todos ellos por
supuesto para ponerse de acuerdo como
cosa rara los políticos no se ponen de
acuerdo pues cuando se tienen que poner
de acuerdo en momentos de mayor crisis
pero bueno alemania ya intervino danny
sino filiales del gigante ruso gazprom
así es desde ahora el regulador
energético alemán se convertirá en el
administrador de gazprom a alemania o
por lo menos hasta el 30 de septiembre y
esta es una manera de asegurar el
suministro de energía porque el gobierno
dice que si no hace esto la empresa
hubiera podido cambiarles las
condiciones a los contratos de gas que
av
en este momento alemania tiene una gran
dependencia de importaciones de energía
rusa y junto con polonia han dicho que
buscarán un sustituto al menos para el
petróleo lo antes posible
los compradores rusos de petróleo sin
embargo pues están divididos hay unos
que ya suspendieron australia reino
unido canadá y eeuu mientras que todavía
le siguen comprando la unión europea
china india e indonesia y se han venido
beneficiando también de los buenos
precios que les ofrecen en rusia por una
menor demanda que tienen ahorita ni que
nos trae como cifra bueno como a usted
le va a gustar la cifra del día a raúl
señoras cuales se centra el día tiene
que ver con twitter porque subió un 27%
en la jornada anterior en wall street
después de que hilo en mosca el
multimillonario dueño de tesla pues
anunciara que va a comprar un 92 por
ciento de la compañía la empresa ya
tiene 40 mil millones de dólares en
bolsa
en valor de la bolsa y le tengo una
noticia también de última hora y es que
se conoció que el dueño de tesla ahora
va a tener una silla en la junta
directiva de twitter lo primero que hizo
fue el la encuesta que le dije
preguntarle a la gente quieren o no
quieren un botón de editar no no señora
lo que se dijo se dijo y que ahí dice
que para la perpetuidad gracias de allí
entonces por toda la información
económica nos vemos mañana con más vamos
directo a parís